THE CATION ANDO ART DOWNPLAYG A
IT.
POLITIFACTTH
OF THE YEAR SANGT
S A
AS
IT COMES WT THE 2021 ES STOLEN.
NOGED ELECTIONHE ELECTION AN
E STEALING O
THOSE RESPONSIBLE FOR HELD ACCO.
ITAS A CORRUPT ELECTIO
TH RIGGED.
, OULDEVED A YEAR AG
RU
D THE  I THE
RE WAY HE
TO MANU,'T
YOU KNOW, MAYBE IN THE OP THAT L
CANDID B PERSON WHO DID
NOAS PRESIDENT
ISMUCHER
NO ONE WANO  A
ST,TH JER ANDOCTSTHE , ISHA
REPUBLICAR FEELS
INCREDIBLY EMBOLDENEIN PARUST W
DEMOCRATS' HOL BOTTHE E E HOUSE.
THAT A 40 VOTE MN IN
THTORACOE THE
THPRESIDENCY.
SO
NARROW TO SORT
OF REFLECT ON,OY, HOW COULWE
HAVEON
INSTEAD IT'S, BOY,E TOIN
HOWEVER, I WILL SAY , THUSFA IO
OR MAYBE IN
HE1 ELECTIONS,
L BEENO DON'T  S
LIKEON
AT LEAST THOSE
ARWIEALEOUNGKIN
GOT -- DIDY GOOD JOB OF
WHILE NOT ALIENATING THEENT, WH
TO KEEP HIM AT A DISTANCE AND
ME TRADITIONAL
ERCAN, NOT
TR.
THE CCESSFUL CANDIDATEFOR
THE HO
AS SUCME, ARG TO
UCA DILDING ON TO THE HOUSCA
IDATES WHO WERE SUCC
CAATN'RUIA
SO THIISY THE
AS WE'RE GOING TIT COMING
TO PIN,
IN THESE BATTLEGRO
TRUMP ENDORSED, IS IDATE OR THE
THAT PERSOG TOTHE BEST OF CANDI?
SE CANDIDATECCESSFUL, WHAT THAT
>> EF , AUTP'S STANDING.
PHIL, IS
THE OHIOYOUR.
ABETHER
D TRUMP'S IDEA THAT
HE WON THE ELECTION.
TA L>> I BELIEVE THIS ELECTION
ST
IMANE THE COURAGE TOIT TECHNOLOG
BATTGR THEORKING WITCRATIC
ELECTION.
>> WIN A
TAG LIKE THIS?MARY WHO
PARTULE RACES GG NOW ADING INTOR
TOR --
IS GOING TO BE A
ING MICROS
I THINK HOUSE RACES -- I DON DI
ER YOU'R REDI THINK IT'SOST
ORY AT THIS POINT IN TIME.
MANU, I THINE OF THE MICS, IF Y
ASKED ME ITRHAVE
BEENHEFIGURE AT THIS
INE SAID
HISTORIC PRECEDENCE  MEMBERG TH.
THE REASON THEY' THIS IS
BECAUSE THIS IS WHERTHLIF THEIR
ISN'A PU
PRIM JUST ABOUT EVERY CASE
OURT MS SHIFTED.
E.INK THIS IS THY OF
THE MOMENT.
YOU WATCH WHERCANDIDATESE GOINGE
IN THE MAGMOVEMENT OR AS A
BECAUSE THEY FEEL IT'S THE ONLY
>>STEAD, HOWYOIT TA GREAT POINT.
E  ELECTEDS,N THE POLITICAL CLAA
BEANT TO OR USE
THEY ENJOY
IN A LOT OF D
CONVERALL
HA, F THAT POLITICLL SAY IT'A C
REPUBLICALIKE THE GEORGIA SENA
OF THE BASE THATLAE T
NNEMTHESE AR
ARE TAKING CUES FROM THEIR TOWN
HALLS FROM THEIRITAND FROM A PA
CHALLENGE FOR REPUICUT
IT'S L AN ONGOING CIVIL
WAR AND MOREF HAT
HAS
McHIKNOW, IN WASNG THERE'SZ CHE
WLOOK
REPUBLTIONAC THE COUNTRY AND
ROM THAT TR P.
EAD.CONGRESSREETRE WE'VE  OAN
IN 2022024, BU  IOAN THE
REPUANL.AUREN, THIS ALL COMES A
E ITAR
HOURS OR IMPED STRICTER VOTER T
I. REQUIREMENT OTHING IN PLACE
PERSONNEL TO PENN TIONULT.
S ENL ZONA
TH THE
TO REPLACE AICWI
ITS OWN.
HOW WORRIED SHOULD THEC BE
ABOUT STATES SUBVERTING THE WILL
OF VOTERS IN 2024 ORN IN
N HI
DE WRI
YEAR FROJUILD R TO AUSN E D OF T
VOTINGS LEGISLATION HEPASS
HAVING AERIES SATIONS OF PHONE
CALLS, A SERIES OF MS
T PEN, HOW TH CONVINCE SENATO
MANCHIN, SENATORA TO
POTENTIALLY ANES T
BECAUSE THEY'RE SO DEEPLERNED AR
TOTIALLY LIMIT TRIGHTS OAMVOTE.F
THANS TO VOTE.EW T A DEEPLY,
DEEPLY IMPORTANT ISSUE.
I THINK T  DC
CONS AS A MPORTA
, YOU KNOW
REPUICT THAT W, I THIN WE'VEN ON
T LEAST THERE'IN DOING T THE FEE
REINAT STATES ARE DOIN
VOTING
UBLICANS CALL IT A FEDERAL